foreign
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show all of a
sudden patriotic Bud Light is facing a
boycott from the right wing because of a
partnership with Dylan Mulvaney who has
become a Flashpoint transgender
influencer so let's see I want to make
sure I'm explaining all of this
correctly Pat Dylan Mulvaney
is a trans woman
who is very much disliked by many of
like the daily wire people and people on
the right honestly I don't know why I
think it's just because she got some
attention from Joe Biden right Joe Biden
kind of like wishing her well that must
be it I didn't know who Dylan Mulvaney
was before this story apparently she is
a highly influential social media
personality on Tick Tock and Instagram
but it's just amazing how the right wing
is so into pop culture seemingly more so
than the left are yeah boy because like
like I said I didn't know who she was
and you barely are aware of her as well
so the whole dust up is because
Budweiser sent Dylan a Bud Light can
that was personalized with her face on
it commemorating being a girl for 365
days
um there was this video Mulvaney it's
called day 365 of girlhood it's a video
series it's had viral success it's sort
of like as charted Dylan's transition
and of course right-wing social media
users are saying this is absolutely
terrible it's time to boycott Bud Light
it's time to boycott and the entire
company Anheuser-Busch and and so on and
so forth this has happened to other
brands Hershey's did a campaign with a
trans rights activist on some chocolate
bar wrappers in Canada for international
women's day there were calls for a
boycott there and uh now this is the
call so what's really interesting about
this is I have to tell you Pat
I think Bud Light is just terrible beer
I don't drink Bud Light at this point at
my age and sort of like in my Social
Circles no one I know drinks Bud Light
the people who seem to drink Bud Light
culturally seem to actually be the right
Wingers that are really angry about this
so so I actually love it for that reason
because it goes right to the heart of
this cultural element that is
overwhelmingly more popular among the
American right wing as far as I can tell
well as far as the taste of Bud Light
goes I'll agree that it's not the best
but I will say it's probably the best
among the cheap beers like I would rank
it over Miller Lite and Coors Light so I
don't know the best of the worst we can
say yeah but yeah I mean this is
probably not going to be a boycott that
lasts very long because I think the
right will eventually just forget about
it you mentioned Hershey's there's so
many other brands too that they've tried
to boycott over the years like remember
uh Nike during the Colin Kaepernick era
uh there's Starbucks because they
decided to hire a bunch of refugees in
response to Trump's travel ban the NFL
apparently the right is still boycotting
or maybe they aren't I have no idea I'm
not sure Disney's the new one as well so
it's all these different brands it just
seems so incredibly difficult to keep
track of it yeah it just becomes so
implausible at a certain point not to
mention the the people with all of these
boycotts are the ones who said they were
against boycotts when it was like hey we
kind of think you shouldn't advertise
with Tucker Carlson now they're
boycotting everything
yeah and over this issue in particular
it doesn't seem to make a whole lot of
sense because I mean the right claims
that trans people are a threat to
America because I don't know they're
trying to Target the children with drag
shows or whatever the case may be but in
this instance if there was just a
commemorative Bud Light can that they
sent over to Dylan Mulvaney how is that
affecting Society at all how is this
impacting the kids how is this a
political issue in the slightest and how
is this worthy of being boycotted over
it just doesn't make any sense at all
none of it makes any sense but honestly
on this one go ahead and boycott the Bud
Light I could not care less one way or
the other it really makes no difference
to me do you think that this could have
any impact at all even if it's like a
two percent decline a five percent maybe
nine in Bud Light sales I just don't
even think that that would be enough for
the company to change course like maybe
they'll they'll they'll think twice
before getting involved in politics or
what could conceivably overlap with the
political realm but that's probably the
best I can help that's the one curiosity
I have is this going to have any impact
at all and if so what happens we'll
follow it and we will see very
interesting story out of North Carolina
that many of you sent me a North
Carolina lawmaker has switched parties
and this is potentially going to open
the door to stricter abortion laws so
here's what's going on this is a
democratic uh North Carolina lawmaker
House member Trisha cotham cotham was a
Democrat ran as a Democrat her mother
was a long time Democratic member of a
commission and DN State DNC her father
was chair of the country's Democrat uh
counties Democratic Party
she previously served in the House of
Representatives in North Carolina from
2007 to 2016 and returned in January her
stance on a number of issues is
consistent with the Democratic party
she's against new abortion restrictions
she supports LGBT rights supports public
education but recently she's had a
couple of votes that have been with the
Republican party she required this
included voting on a bill requiring
sheriffs to cooperate with ice which is
something many on the left don't like
and a couple of other issues so the
important thing that's going on
is that early yesterday cotham announced
she's going to switch from being a
Democrat to a republican she says she's
been bullied by democrats and so she is
switching this would give the Republican
Party 72 seats in the house that's
exactly the number you need for a veto
proof majority it has the numbers in the
Senate meaning that Republicans will be
able to enact policies over the
opposition of the governor who's a
Democrat Roy Cooper so essentially Pat
this means that Republicans can do
whatever they want in the state other
than things that would be challenged for
legal reasons because they have veto
proof majorities in both the state house
and the state senate so this is
immediately calling raising calls for
Trisha cotham to resign I got uh people
asking me should this trigger
um a recall election because she ran as
a Democrat and now she's she switched
and it was it's deceptive and it's
fraudulent this is a really complicated
situation well I'd imagine Trisha cotham
is not going to resign over this just
like how Kirsten Cinema didn't resign
when she became an independent in
Arizona and my question is is this
actually caught them having a change of
heart having some sort of political
Awakening or does she just see the
opportunity and feel as though okay well
if I make this switch then maybe I'll be
able to raise my name recognition in the
state and potentially run for a higher
office as a republican is this really
just to further her own interests or is
this something that she genuinely wanted
to do because she felt as if the left
was bullying her too much or whatever
bogus reason she came up with my guess
is that it was just based on personal
interests and with regards to like a
recall I I mean I don't know what the
the law is on the books right now in
North Carolina but you can't just if if
a recall election process doesn't
already exist you can't try to go about
doing that you just have to to wait for
her to serve out the term and then try
to get her out of office in the next
election so North Carolina does not
provide for recall through state law but
more than 500 individual municipalities
um I I guess have recall Provisions
although in many cases they've never
actually been used so I don't even know
that she can be recalled because this
would be a state level
uh well it's not state level because it
would just be the district that she
represents but it's it's not obvious
that there is even the provision to
recall her I suppose you could put the
blame back on the voters because my
sense is that Gotham wasn't like a true
out and out Progressive right because
like imagine a scenario where Bernie
Sanders or AOC decided to leave the
Democratic party and become a republican
right it's just totally inconceivable
that sort of thing would never happen
um and if voters thought that they were
electing a progressive in Gotham then um
you know they wouldn't run into that
sort of risk but they did have
alternatives to her they could have
picked someone else in the primary who
they thought would be more to the left
of her true and have no shot of ever
switching to the Republican party or
even voting with Republicans at any
point so they decided ultimately to pick
her in the primary you could kind of
place the blame back on voters knowing
that there would be the potential for
this to happen but but you know this
it's probably sad in this instance that
there isn't a recall election because it
is so much fraudulent right she was
elected as a Democrat you would want her
to stick out the term as a Democrat I
think the best I'm not making this
argument but I think the best argument
that you could make for What scenario
could lead to her forcible removal would
be one that there's no evidence for and
it would be as follows if you could show
Pat that she was in League with
Republicans when she ran she planned to
do this and and maybe even Republicans
supported her financially in some way in
running as a Democrat with the idea of
eventually flipping to a republican if
you could demonstrate that and again I'm
not alleging that that happened I'm just
saying hypothetically there are laws and
I don't know if these are federal or
state laws which prevent the running of
straw candidates this came up in Florida
when it seemed as though Matt Gates was
maybe involved in running some straw
candidate in 2018 like the details or
maybe it was 2020 I don't remember now
if you could make an argument Under The
Struck hand that it rules and you could
demonstrate that this was a plot from
the beginning by Republicans and funded
by Republicans with Gotham's knowledge
I think then and only then would you be
able to say she's gotta go and again I
don't believe that the facts point to
that being the case I suppose that
overlaps with the logic that many are
using to try to oust George Santos which
is this idea that Santos ran as someone
who he actually isn't right he claimed
to have all these credentials that he
doesn't have and if voters were aware of
who the real George Santos was they
wouldn't have voted for him but you can
also say that it's really the it's
really incumbent on the candidates who
are running against whoever ends up
winning the election uh to do their due
diligence to the opposition research and
to bring these issues to the attention
of the voters the voters should
ultimately decide like if there was a
real failure here it seems to have been
on the part of the people running
against her and uh you know if the
voters didn't want someone who was like
a true Progressive who had absolutely no
risk of ever going to the Republican
Party well then ultimately that's the
person that they chose yeah so where I
come down on this is that it's highly
unfortunate but assuming you can't
recall her you're just gonna have to
wait until the next election probably we
will follow it and see if and what
further Fallout there is a number of you
sent me an article of a judge ordering
Stormy Daniels to pay Donald Trump a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars in
legal fees and that is absolutely true
in a completely unrelated case Donald
Trump was in New York getting arrested
criminally a judge in Los Angeles
granted Trump a legal Victory the uh NPR
reports that the ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals ruled in favor of trump and told
Stormy Daniels the very same adult film
star who is partially connected to the
34 felony counts in New York City stormy
has to pay Trump 121 thousand dollars in
legal fees for a failed defamation suit
she tried to file suit for defamation
against Trump that is not going forward
and now she owes Trump legal fees I
think there's not that much to discuss
Pat about the case in so far as this has
been going on for a while there are
other defamation suits there's the E
Gene Carroll one it's going to take a
while for all of these things to be
adjudicated the important thing is that
the timing
is confusing some people into thinking
that this portends victory for Trump
criminally in New York City criminal and
civil are completely different things
the jurisdictions are completely
separate the charges we're talking about
criminal charges in New York this was
defamation there is no connection other
than Stormy Daniels name between these
two cases and I don't think it's wise to
read anything into this decision when
you're trying to explore what will
happen in New York City right there is
no overlap to be drawn here I'd imagine
many on the right will point to this and
show that it's proof that somehow the
affair didn't take place or Trump
shouldn't be criminally charged but the
two things have nothing to do with one
another interestingly enough Daniel said
that she wouldn't have brought this
defamation suit forward if not for the
influence of Michael avenatti and
because you know he's now sitting in
prison right now and you know his name
has been completely tarnished I wonder
if um you know that would go anywhere to
uh help her case but apparently not
because this judgment now has ruled that
she has to pay for Trump's legal
expenses I also wonder if like if this
um when this initially went down back in
2018 when we started to hear about this
case when Michael Cohen was being
prosecuted for it if there was more of
an attention paid to Trump and there was
a willingness at that time to go after
Trump criminally if they ever would have
brought this defamation case if it would
have ever had to get to that level
because I kind of get the sense that
Stormy Daniels in a representation at
that point wanted to hold Trump
accountable for what took place but they
realized it wasn't going to happen in
the criminal court at least at that time
so this is how they decided to go about
doing it I agree I think that it's quite
plausible that had it was there more of
a sense that Trump would actually
I held accountable is too much right
because just because you've been charged
doesn't mean you're being held
accountable but that was even the
possibility of criminal charges I think
that this defamation suit may not have
gone forward but this is where we are
right now and a judge has decided Stormy
Daniels does owe Trump the legal fees
what's funny is Trump rarely Pays His
lawyers from what we know but on that
issue he has to have fronted some money
for all of this criminal defense work
that he's having done now right like or
could it be that even now these lawyers
just want the publicity and they're
willing to wait on payment which may
never come could that be I honestly have
no idea I mean the publicity could be
enough for these lawyers because
obviously this is going to get a whole
bunch of attention and it's going to
help them further their careers at the
same time I'd imagine that if Trump was
ever going to pay lawyers for any sort
of case this would be the one because
this is the one that conceivably result
in him ending up in prison so this is
the one that you'd actually want to pay
people for uh but I'm I'm 50 50 on that
one I don't know if they're actually
getting paid or if they'll ever get paid
quick reminder next week Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday I will be off and we
will have a number of different great
guest hosts I will be hosting tomorrow's
Friday show I'll be off Monday through
Thursday back Friday and then the
following week as well so just as a
heads up to everybody but before any of
that we'll be back tomorrow with a new
show and a new bonus trip